need motivation what it thought then
with relief nation hey this is Alex
sayin and I'm with Evan Carmichael hey
this is Alex an and ever created this
channel to help you overcome the number
one challenges holding you back and that
is a lack of belief in yourself so get
ready for some mind shift setting so get
ready for some mindset shifting what so
get ready for some mindset shifting
advice from Evan Carmichael to help you
with motivation confidence and believe
it you need so let's kick it off with
rule number one take action now I'm
going to teach you a strategy right now
that will change your life it's called
the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you get
an idea for something as soon as you get
an idea for a new thing that you want to
try out you go do it and it's called the
two percent difference because most
people when they come up with an idea
what they do is they think about it they
plan they strategize right you got an
idea to go launch something great you go
home you strategize you you think are
you playing you think about it but then
you wake up tomorrow a different person
you wake up tomorrow a different person
you are feeling bold yesterday you can
with this great bold bold vision for
yourself amazing you're feeling on top
of the world yesterday you wake up
tomorrow a different person and then you
don't do anything about it
maybe we research a little bit more and
then that idea is dead I believe that
the decisions that you make when you're
feeling bold unstoppable and confident
are actually the right ones for you and
then your head talked to you down from
doing them we just don't live in the
land of bold and confidence 24/7 we
spend 1% of our life if that feeling
bold and confident and the other 90
nothing feeling scared and afraid and
back down to where we were before so the
decisions you make when you're feeling
bold and confident are the right ones
for you and therefore the first step you
need to take is not planning is not
strategizing is not thinking it's action
the two percent difference what that
means is instead of going home and
strategizing and planning on how to get
to a hundred percent of your goal build
immediate momentum of how to get the two
percent of your goal focus on taking
action to get 2% of the way close to
hitting your goal and then that momentum
will carry you forward to helping you
get through to the rest of the hundred
so here's an example I'm filming this
from Las Vegas
I'm on this tour right now I promised
Nina I made a decision I'm gonna take me
in every city in North America with a
million plus people that was the goal
that I had great most people would go
home start researching thinking how many
cities are there in North America with a
million plus people how we're gonna do
it Nina has a full-time job on and on
and on and on with all the reasons why
you're not gonna be able to do it you
start planning and strategizing great no
that's not the way to do it because you
wake up tomorrow different persons say I
don't know about that goal like I can't
do that
and you start talking yourself down from
it so while you're feeling the boldness
of it when you're feeling capable when
you actually feel capable of
accomplishing that goal you go off and
you do something so I said great this
weekend I'm gonna go to Boston Nina had
never been to Boston so this weekend
we're gonna go to Boston and I message
her to see Nina I've decided I'm gonna
take you to every city in North America
with a million-plus people and this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston turns
out the 50 cities on the list I don't
know how I'm gonna get to my 50 cities
yet but I can hit one and that's 2% if
you cannot get to the first 2%
immediately you will never get to the 50
you'll never get to the hundred she's
never gonna happen this is the problem
for most entrepreneurs you plan too much
you strategize too much you think too
much you're too smart we're smart and so
you find really smart reasons why you
can't do something you're a
perfectionist you're worried about
putting something out before it's ready
and then you never release it the people
who have met on this tour I feel so bad
for them I but it blows my mind of
people who've waited decades plus to
move forward and their idea that idea
that you have that you're sitting on
you'll do something about it right now
that's the difference there are dummies
dummies dummies who are winning in your
industry who don't have as much
intellect as you who don't have as much
passion as you who don't have as much of
a heart and a cause of wanting to do
something good to serve as you do and
they're winning and you're not why
because they're actually off doing the
work and you're sitting on your couch at
home strategizing researching planning
thinking about it and being too afraid
to go off and take action and so the 2%
difference the next time you feel
yourself coming up with an idea when we
get ideas all the time you get an idea
train yourself idea trusted it comes
from somewhere right that idea comes
from somewhere don't judge it don't be
critical of it it came from some
you have a responsibility to do
something about it idea to action idea
to action train yourself idea to action
it's always something today you saw
something in the shower great idea
do something I do the action the 2%
difference stop planning your way on how
to get to a hundred percent of your goal
and figure out what can you do right now
today immediately to get 2% of the way
start applying that principle it will
change your life rule number two change
your mindset I'm gonna give you the most
important strategy that the next time
you're feeling frustrated you're feeling
defeated you're feeling like giving up
will save you and help you find that
inner strength and next gear here it is
tell yourself it's the best the next
time you're feeling down frustrated
depressed angry tell yourself it's the
best because now this is your chance to
show yourself and the world what you're
made of the next time you're stuck at a
red light and you're frustrated and
complaining it's the best the next time
you're working out and you feel like
you're on your last scent your your
lungs are on fire and you can't push
again it's the best the next time you're
frustrated in business that you're not
getting the sales you need and you feel
like you're waking up every day and
there's no momentum it's the best it's
the best this is your chance this is
your chance you can complain for seven
and a half seconds and get frustrated
and then tweak it inside your brain to
say this is the best why what does it do
first it switches your mindset to one of
hopelessness to one of the
resourcefulness it switches your mindset
from one of hopelessness that this sucks
that I'm giving up I'm defeated it's
over why does this happen to me why does
this son to one of resourcefulness that
this is the best this is my chance
because you grow through challenges and
this is the next challenge in front of
me that I am going to grow through rule
number three change your perspective
most entrepreneurs can't handle a major
setback you can't you can handle a whole
bunch of little setbacks a little bit of
punch to the face but you can't handle a
major setback when there's a major
meltdown what do you do to get back up
you find another way or do you quit and
most entrepreneurs most businesses will
quit look at how many companies are
still around look at the biggest
companies in the world how many of them
were around 100 years ago
not very many most companies go to
business because they can adjust it
can't evolve they don't love the dark
clouds enough let's look at YouTube as
an example whenever there's a major
algorithm change everybody's upset
everybody's complaining everybody is
freaking out like I don't like it I
don't like it
right they complain I get pumped I get
pumped because it's my chance to win now
it's sucks because it's a lot of work
because you got to figure out a new path
but everybody who's ahead of you who's
complaining that's your chance to win
and so I'm going through it right now
I look at my channel and making three
videos a day might be set back to my
channel even this video I don't know
where it's gonna be it might be on my
main channel might be on a sub channel
that I'm making it's a big potential
strategic shift for me to say going from
one channel to three or eight haven't
fully figured it out yet but I'm pumped
I'm pumped while other people are
suffering and struggling and complaining
that this is the new YouTube I'm gonna
test it out immediate action let's go
it's not that loving the dark clouds at
least for me it's not that loving the
dark clouds you want negativity to
happen you want there to be controversy
you want chaos to happen you want your
competitors go out of business you want
it to be difficult it's not that it's
that that's your chance to win and so
the best thing I recommend is flip it in
your head
learn to tell yourself that this is the
best when everybody else is complaining
when everybody else is struggling even
when you when you put all this work into
doing something and now it's collapsing
on you it's really hard to stay positive
tell yourself this is the best this is
my opportunity to prove to myself in the
world what I'm made of and then if you
can move from a place of resourceless
nests to resourcefulness and find a path
while everybody else is ahead of you and
complaining that's your chance to win
Rula before be patient entrepreneurs
generally don't have a lot of patience
and that's actually a good thing we want
things now we want to hustle hard we
want to see the results of our labour
paying off we want to see you know
change happening we have a big vision we
know it can work and we want it to
happen right now and that's that's
that's a
amazing I want you to hold on to it and
at the same time I want you to have
incredible patience because what ends up
happening is entrepreneurs often quit
too soon you had the right idea you had
the right vision you even had the right
execution certain it up but you just
quit you fires gonna happen in three
months where it's actually gonna happen
in three years for what you're doing
every single day you need to be applying
yourself and closed-off every
opportunity for four years and then
you'll be successful
four years ago on my youtube channel I
had 7,000 ish subscribers four years ago
how did I get here with 1.2 million by
making videos every single day every
single day we haven't missed a day in
four years and in the past two or three
years has been three times a day or at
least two times a day just grinding it
out and in those little micro moments in
those micro videos it's super impatience
right it's like this video has to
deliver this video not has to deliver
this next one this one right here has to
deliver there's a lot of impatience to
make things happen and it's knowing that
this is going to take me years to get to
where I want to go also if you want to
have more confidence check out our to 54
series the links to join our description
below surround yourself with greatness
if you want to be more confident you
need to surround yourself with things
that make you feel confident find
whatever the smallest first step is and
then the smallest next step is and
continue to build those steps I mean you
look back you'll have realized that you
made some pretty significant progress
sir rule number five live your truth
most people aren't happy in life because
they're living somebody else's truth
you're not living your truth you're
living somebody else's version of it
your parents your family your culture
your society you live in somebody else's
version of it and so you're never happy
because you never explored it you never
picked at it you never found out what
you could be and you settle for
something less than what you're capable
of you know you're capable of more you
may not know what the thing is that you
should be doing but you know it's not
this thing right in front of you I can't
tell you how many people I've met on
this tour who have that story to share I
had a woman whose father told her that
women should not be doing any kind of
entrepreneurial ventures that women are
meant to be teachers and so she spent 15
years being a teacher before having a
courage to jump off and start her own
business and now she has a multi-million
dollar construction business I had a
girl come up in Albuquerque where I am
right now
who studied for years to be an
accountant why because her mom was
accountant so her mom made her go
studied to become an accountant and she
didn't know what she wanted to do as if
she said okay great yeah I'll be an
accountant she just graduated and
realized I don't want to be an
accountant this isn't for me it's easy
it's the path that my parents took like
it's bring for me to get into it I can
get easy money you know my mom said I
like it when the money starts coming in
but money's coming in and I don't like
it I want to do something else I know
I'm meant for something greater and so
she told her mom I don't want to do this
I want to learn how to be a management
consultant am I going to go back to
school that takes a lot of guts that
takes a lot of courage most people do
not have that courage most people do not
have the courage to stand up to their
parents and say I don't want this life
it doesn't mean you have to hate them
you have to attack them you have to tell
them they're wrong this is for you you
don't want that life most people never
had that courage and the story that
comes to mind for me is actual moretta
and use this as motivation as wisdom if
you are trying to battle your parents or
your culture your friends your society
remember akio morita he started Sony now
he came from 11 or 12 generations of
sake Brewers Japanese background the
Japanese culture is super
family oriented and the oldest always
takes over the family business
oldest has to follow in line with what
the family was doing and so he was
expected to take over the sake business
and it's not just one generation you're
talking eleven to twelve generations in
a Japanese society and he said I don't
want to do this I want to start my own
business a technology company at a time
when Japan was known for super low
quality products this is the man who put
Japan on the Mac for high quality
products that products coming out of
Japan meant something was a stamp of
quality because of Akio Morita and he
went on to build one of the most
successful brands in the world and Sony
but it starts with having the courage
having a courage to say that's not my
life that's not my truth rule number six
surround yourself with greatness this is
why I keep going with my youtube channel
this is the reason why I keep going with
my youtube channel because yes your
spouse is important and yes your friends
important and the people that you hang
out with our super super super important
and all the other people that you hang
out with by reading books and consuming
content watching videos all of that
makes an impact to the more that you
spend hanging around people and ideas
and wisdom that bring you up the more
you're going to rise up and the more
you're around people who are complaining
and negative and pulling you down guess
what happens the more you're gonna be
pulled down and one of the big reasons
for me in creating this channel was I
wanted to be around successful
entrepreneurs I wanted to be around
people who would push me to go off and
do more because in my life I'm super
fortunate to have a very understanding
wife a very supportive family friends
who encouraged me in
always support the things that I'm doing
but I don't have people who are pushing
me to do better you know I don't have
people who say you know what what you're
doing is great but you should be out
here like you could be making these
adjustments and playing a bigger game
you can have a bigger impact and so I
needed more of that in my life
and so my solution defining it was was
the videos was I want a hanger-on Elon
Musk and I want to hang around Steve
Jobs don't want to hang around Warren
Buffett I want to hang around these
people who are thinking on a bigger
scale because the more you do that the
more you ingest this content the more
you're gonna think like them the more
you're gonna act like them the more
you're gonna take these pieces to not
only just be like them but to be the
best version of you rule number seven
don't try to please everybody to listen
everybody's gonna have an opinion on
what you should do with your life
everybody your your friends your family
your culture your society your community
your customers online haters everybody's
got an opinion on what you should do
with your life and it's tempting to want
to take the advice one because it gives
us advice but two it is also somebody to
blame right like if it doesn't work out
it's not my fault is that person's fault
they said I should do it at some point
though you have to decide that you are
gonna be an adult that you are in
control that you want to go off and
build your own life and you only you
know what that looks like and you have
to have the courage to the confidence to
step up and say I'm in charge this is my
life now I get to decide what I want to
do and some opinions will matter and
some opinions will make a difference and
others you have to let bounce off you
you're not gonna be able to please
everybody everybody has an opinion on
what you should do with your life and
the only one that really matters truly
is this one right here
so how do you decide how do you know
what the difference is how do you know
which opinions you should take which you
should listen to because on the one hand
it's you want to take advice you want to
take counsel you don't know everything
and then the other hand it's it's your
life you gotta decide how do you make
those two things work together
number one is understand what your one
word is your one word is the most
important core value
mine is believe yours is whatever it is
it's worth going through the exercise I
think is one of the most important
exercises you can ever do in your life
it becomes a filter through which you
see the world and so for me it's belief
believe is around believing in yourself
having self-confidence believing in the
work that you're doing having passion
for it and believing that it's gonna
work out believe it in the impact
believing that there is light at the end
of the tunnel even if you only see
darkness around you right now that's
believed and so all of the decisions
that I make are through the lens of
believe every new piece of content and I
put on my channel is through the lens of
belief and so you give me advice that
has nothing to do with believe it may be
great potential advice but it's not for
me how do I know what's for me because
I'm sitting on my rock of believe and if
you don't know what value you stand on
it's easy to get pulled in a lot of
different directions rule number eight
be consistent will summers don't win
because they're not consistent in us
it's not because you don't have talent
or skills or energy you're just not
consistent enough you're not consistent
enough too many entrepreneurs get all
pumped up and motivated and you're
working like crazy and you have an
amazing day and then the next day you
wake up and you're back to your normal
life and you're not consistently putting
in the effort the reason why my YouTube
channel has one is because I made videos
every single day for five years five
years ago plus I had seven thousand
subscribers on my youtube channel now
we're over 1.8 million not because I'm
super talented I'm not go back watch my
videos you'll see how I sucked at the
beginning super nervous awkward in a
suit sitting down just terrible but by
making videos every single day I got
better and I was able to conquer what I
didn't have any natural talent in
because I learned to develop the skill
by beating on my craft every single day
and so this is one of the major problems
for entrepreneurs I think a lot of
people could have done what I've done I
think a lot of you watching you could
have done what I've done you have more
natural talent than I do the difference
is I got up every day for five years and
did it and so I don't think it's that
special I think it's just putting in the
effort in the hustle every single day
and that's a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs don't win you are just not
consistent enough in your effort rule
number nine find your genius like I say
that everybody has Michael Jordan level
talent is something I believe it I think
I think you have Michael Jordan level
talent or something I think your genius
a legit bona fide
you should be off there change in the
world I believe it I think you have that
talent I think you have that
capabilities most people don't most
people one they don't believe in
themselves enough to actually go off and
chase it most people too don't go off
and explore to find the thing that they
have genius at that they could be
Michael Jordan's not warm before that
and instead you try to photocopy
somebody else's life you try to be the
next somebody no you're a genius let's
go let's chase it down that's why I'm on
my mission I want to solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
I think everybody is that genius and
they either don't know what the thing is
that they should be doing or they don't
believe in themselves hard enough to go
and chase it down so let's work through
those two things whatever can't be fall
into there's gonna be advice that will
help you one you don't know what your
genius at amazing what's the past you
explore you test you try people settle
way too early in life you settle you
settle how do you know if you like sushi
or not until you taste it you don't you
should be trying everything I think
everybody should try to be an
entrepreneur everybody should try to
have a YouTube channel everybody should
try to have a podcast everybody should
try to be an accountant like you should
try she pick up everything just to get a
sense say yes to everything once adopt
that mindset mentality we get locked in
to career paths way too soon why because
that's what our parents did because
that's what we want to school for why
you're gonna now live the rest of your
life doing something because you've only
tried five different things and now
you're gonna pick like that's the recipe
for disaster
that's why ninety-five percent of
America wakes up and drives to the job
that they hate you have to try you have
to say yes and don't tie your self-worth
to the results you will suck at the
beginning
whatever you first start doing you will
suck it will not work out my first
youtube videos sucked sucked go back
watch him so you can see how bad I was
when I first started my videos I sucked
I was awkward I was nervous I was
introverted it's likely 350 videos until
I wasn't completely embarrassed by
myself 350 videos and so the acid test
needs to be do you like the process do
you want to go back and do it again you
may not have been good at it but you
want to go off and do it again so you
need to say yes to a whole bunch of
things when you don't know what you want
to do in life you need to say yes to
almost everything as long as it falls
within your personal you know values
ethics you
harming yourself you know those things
you should go off and try I think you
should try I don't think you've tried
enough if you don't know what you want
to do in life you have not tried enough
rule number ten don't obsess with
perfection stop trying to be perfect one
of the biggest things that holds
entrepreneurs back is you have an idea
in your head and you want to launch it
but you're afraid to launch anything
until it's perfect you're afraid to put
anything out into the world until you
have the perfect plan the perfect
product the perfect competitive
advantage and that does not exist and
the biggest danger of all is that just
stays an idea for you for the rest of
your life that it never actually gets
created because you can never reach
perfection because you're afraid of
releasing the thing out into the world
and so you never will or everybody who
you look up to the people who've had
massive success any entrepreneur they
release something before it was perfect
they got feedback they adjusted they
listened to it and that became the thing
that propelled them to massive success
and so you need to move from that place
of trying to have everything be a
hundred percent perfect before you
launch and just get used to actually
creating actually doing actually putting
stuff out there into the market instead
of sitting on your couch hoping wishing
dreaming planning strategizing but never
actually do it
rule number eleven belief whether you
believe you can't you can't you're right
right whether you believe you can or you
can't
you're right one of the biggest reasons
why aren't repairs don't win because you
don't believe in yourself enough that's
why why do I have this channel
why is my one word belief look look at
the back of Nina's sweater there it is
right believe believe that's it it's so
important there's so many you guys are
geniuses as so many geniuses massively
talented people out there with amazing
ideas that can change the world but you
don't walk in crush because you don't
believe in yourself enough I think the
two biggest problems in the world are
one recognizing that you have Michael
Jordan level talent is something believe
in that you have something in you that
you're not meant to just wake up and
photocopy your life every day working
for somebody else just believing that
and to then believing in that ability
believing that you have Michael Jordan
level talent or something and then when
you found it believing in and enough to
chase it down everyday to get better
because you need to beat on your craft
because it may be something that's
totally outside what is normal in your
family because it may be something way
outside what is normal for your culture
or your society or your community but
you have to go often do that crazy thing
and it's really hard to believe in
yourself enough to chase it down
especially when it's against what
everybody around you is saying and what
they believe and so great yes I need to
believe in myself amazing how do you do
it what's the process how do you gain
self belief you need to eliminate the
negativity in your life and replace it
with belief so think about what are the
thoughts who are the people what are the
things around you that keep you where
you are to keep these negative patterns
in your head is it your parents is it
your friends is it the TV shows you're
watching the media consuming like what
is it that is toxic that makes you feel
small and as much as possible
you either cuddle your life or reduce
the exposure if it's your mom who's
always on you and says you can't go be
an entrepreneur maybe you just don't
talk about your career with your mom you
put boundaries up I don't want to talk
about this there's other things that we
haven't come when you focus on that
stuff
you lay out the ground rules you make
them respect you and you don't talk
about the things that you know is gonna
lead to conflict and for other people
you may need to just completely cut them
out of your life if it's your best
friend from growing up just because you
have friends in great Ford doesn't mean
you should still be friends of adults a
lot of our friendships are out of
convenience you're with people just
because it's convenient to be with
people but you've grown apart and you
have to recognize that if somebody's
toxic around you you shouldn't be with
them and if you are it's micro doses and
so you need to cut out a lot of the crap
in your life anything that's causing
negativity or self-doubt needs to be
eliminated from your life as much as
possible
great now you have a vacuum now you've
got this whole mothers that is this void
inside you great what do you do you fill
it up with positivity you fill it up
with beliefs my channels are pretty good
reasonably I got this channel I got the
other channels you got three videos plus
a day coming out across my channels that
if you want more beliefs on your life
here's a great resource for you but
forget about me it's not about me it's
about
what makes you feel beliefs if it's
watching videos great if it's listening
to a podcast reading the book doing an
active service meditating prayer
whatever the thing is that helps you
feel beliefs do that every single day
fill yourself up with it I inject myself
with so much vitamin C belief ic belief
is an injection and put it into myself
every day I have so much of it in me
that if somebody sneezes their toxicity
on me I'm not gonna get sick because
I've because I'm surrounded with so much
belief that's what you need for your
life as well rule number 12 know your
why step number 2 is your why why do you
do what you do your purpose comes from
your pain your purpose comes from your
pain the thing that you will enjoy the
most in life is helping people who
currently are going through whatever you
massively struggled with think about the
biggest pain in your life whatever that
was growing up the biggest pain the
thing you'd never want to have to repeat
or go through again that pain that pain
that deep dark pain you wouldn't wish
upon your enemies that pain the worst
day of your life that pain your greatest
joy in life will be helping people who
are currently going through that pain
and getting them through it that's it
that's your purpose for life that will
never get old that will be with you for
life and so for me starting up as an
entrepreneur was my biggest pain I felt
worthless I was making $300 a month I
was suffering and struggling and just
felt defeated as a human being that's
why I love helping out other
entrepreneurs and that's gonna be it for
life that'll be my purpose for life rule
number 13 don't quit you need to do
things that make you proud of yourself
you need to do the difficult things when
it's hard and you do it and you try and
you keep going that's when you feel
proud about yourself when you quit early
even if everybody gives you a logical
reason for doing and say hey it's okay
don't worry about it quit you should
quit take it easy
but you know deep down inside yourself
you can't quit you have to do the work
that makes you feel proud because if you
face difficulties and then quit that's
what you're teaching yourself that's the
story inside your head and there's no
way you're gonna go off and accomplish
those big bad impossible dream goals of
yours if you
what every time it gets hard I had a guy
come to my Columbus workshop and he had
a goal to do six days a week cold
showers it was Friday night Saturday
night was his day off from cold showers
it was Friday because my workshopping
says it's been winter here in Columbus
I'm at my girlfriend's house all day
today it's been freezing bonanza I've
been inside the house it's been freezing
all day I didn't do my cold shower today
I mean what should I do
should I take my cold shower I said well
are you proud of the reason why not are
you proud of the reason that you're in a
cold house all day and so that's that's
good justification for you said no I'm
not part of the reason great then you
have to do it you have to go take your
cold shower and after the workshop you
got home at 11:30 at night and he took
an Instagram video from from the waist
up getting into the cold shower and
freezing his face off and then I said
you have to go off and do it again
tomorrow - you've been oh Saturday's
your day off you have to get up and do
it again tomorrow just to show yourself
just to prove to yourself what you're
made of when it's difficult and you try
that's when you win that's when you
actually feel good about yourself when
it's difficult and you keep going even
if the results suck even if past the 40%
your results are starting to decline you
feel great about yourself because you
kept going but if you quit as soon as it
gets hard that's what you're teaching
yourself to do and so I see
entrepreneurs and leaders as trees
you're a tree your responsibility as a
tree is to eat poison carbon dioxide
right you eat poison you eat it you grow
from it and then you spit out positivity
and oxygen for the people around you
right for yourself and the people around
you you grow from it your job was to eat
adversity your job is to eat judgment
your job is to eat difficulties and you
grow from it and then you create
opportunities and possibilities for
yourself and the people around you
that's your job and so the next time
that you find yourself in a difficult
situation you want to quit you want to
give up you're at that mark your brain
wants to quit on you remind yourself I'm
a tree
I'm a tree I'm gonna grow from this this
is my chance to get better this is my
chance to eat it to grow from it and
then create possibilities for other
people that's your job if you want to be
an amazing leader an amazing
entrepreneur and I'm cheering for you
Louie number 40 that's a lot ways if you
listen real number 14 be consistent lack
of consistency is one of the biggest
reasons why entrepreneurs fail one of
the biggest reasons you're a genius you
have great ideas you want to serve you
know you're capable of Park and you have
these moments of inspiration and moments
of boldness and moments of massive
productivity and focus and clarity but
it's not consistent and that's why most
entrepreneurs will lose because you
might crush it on a Saturday or Sunday
or Monday but then Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday you fall back down until
the next Saturday when you're up and
flying again it's not enough it's much
more about what you do every day you are
what you consistently do it's a huge
problem for entrepreneurs so let's fix
it number one if you are a part-time
entrepreneur if you work for someone
else your part that much when her you
need to make sure that every single day
you're working on your business every
single day you have to work on your
business no matter what even if it's for
15 minutes at night every single day you
cannot let momentum die even just to
show yourself that you can even if it's
a crazy long day and your boss is
yelling at you and you come home and
your spouse is angry and your kids are
sick even then you have to spend 15
minutes on your business half an hour on
your business every single day you
cannot let the momentum die
don't disappoint yourself number two if
you're already full time when your
business is great you need to have CEO
time every day in your business CEO time
time where you spend being the CEO what
does that mean it's different for
different entrepreneurs but when you're
working on the business instead of in it
if you spend all time just working in
the business just putting out fires and
ever growing guess what you're never
gonna grow if you never have CEO
I'm built into your business you will
never be a CEO and so you need to make
sure that every day you have CEO time
built into your business again maybe
it's only half an hour but in that half
an hour you're spending time growing
your company you're gonna start seeing
results and my last tip is I want you to
start your morning off powerfully I want
you to chart your start I want you to
have a morning routine that inspires you
that makes you feel bold most people
what do they do when they wake up first
thing you do is I hit the snooze button
what does that mean it means last night
you set a goal I'm gonna wake up at a
certain time right I'm gonna wake up at
6 a.m. 5 a.m. 7 a.m. 12 noon I don't
care what time you have to wake up you
set a goal you're gonna wake up and then
the very first thing that you do you
start your day every day just say I am
NOT gonna hit my goal today let's say
you start your day that's how most of
our America starts today they say I'm
not gonna hit my goal today how do you
think you're gonna go off and have an
amazing day and crush it and go get your
crazy big goals and ambitions that you
have as an entrepreneur when you tell
yourself and you reinforce it every
morning that you aren't I'm a person who
doesn't hit their goals you gotta change
- you're gonna wake up wake up when you
see you're gonna wake up get out of bed
when you say you're gonna get out of bed
that's step 1 then step 2 is what is the
morning routine that sets you up for
success most people wake up like it's an
accident they wake up you check your
phone you responding to other people's
emergencies and their agenda for your
time
that's not how you need to start your
day successful people they own their
morning what does your morning look like
and we've all felt inspired and bold at
some point
felt you've been both been inspired at
some point in your life great whatever
that thing was it made you feel both
unstoppable inspired put that into your
morning routine
maybe this watching video if it's
reading the book maybe it's doing an act
kindness maybe it's meditating maybe
it's prayer whatever is what's intention
because some of you have a morning
routine alrighty I'm talking to you you
have a morning routine already but
you're not brushing it every day you're
not coming out of that morning routine
stealing bold inspired consistently
that's what we're talking about
consistency here sometimes you just go
through the motions of your morning
routine sometimes you just pray but
you're not really connecting sometimes
you just watch a video but you're making
your breakfast you're brushing your
teeth are you not paying attention with
intention do your morning routine you
must come out of your morning routine
every single day feeling bold
unstoppable and confident if you did
that if you woke up every day on time
like you say you're going to you're
knocking at the snooze button you get
out of bed and then you did the thing
that made you feel bold powerful and
unstoppable every single day holy cow I
guarantee you your life one year from
today will look dramatically different
than where you are right now consistency
is the game you are what you
consistently do and I want to see you
win rule number 15 and not kill yourself
against judgment the more you live your
life face of what other people think you
fear you're gonna lose you lose this
you're an entrepreneur you want to do
crazy things you have a bold ambitious
vision for what you want to accomplish
in your life you want to change the way
something's done in an industry right
this one we want to do we want to change
the world you know what there's a lot of
people who want to protect the world the
status quo they want to protect the way
things are done you want to come in and
shake up an industry there's a lot of
people who want to protect that industry
there's a lot of people who don't like
change there's a lot of people who are
so afraid of seeing you be successful
because it means that they suck right
there's a lot of people who will in your
environment in your family your home
your friends people who they don't want
to see you win because it means they
suck because you've left them
because it means that they're not good
anymore because they judge themselves
based off of what everybody else is
doing and a lot of people have someone
in their family who went off and crushed
it and they tried it and then they
failed right they tried it so they may
have had some success and then they
failed and now nobody else around them
is allowed to be successful all they
want to do is pull everybody else down
they took their shot ultimately didn't
work
you know they pull everybody else around
them they can't let that be you the more
you want to go off and have a bold
ambitious life for yourself the more
you're gonna have to learn to what I
call inoculate yourself against judgment
you need to inoculate yourself against
judgment the judgment that your friends
your parents the people around you the
general public social media inoculate
yourself against judge truth as long as
you care what other people think of you
you will lose you will play small
forever you will not be living your
version of your life and so how do you
do it how do you not let yourself
against judgment here's how it goes any
time you feel your heart beating boom
boom boom boom boom boom your hearts
beating you're nervous you're scared
what's something to think of you you
have to do the thing you train yourself
even if it's not an expression of you
even if you don't really care about
doing that thing or not you have to do
it just to train yourself something like
this would have been really difficult
for me ten years ago filming on the
street was really hard I'll be worried
about what people think of me be worried
about me standing here San Francisco
people walking by what do you think of
me yelling into my phone yelling into
this microphone here talking to you guys
right here it's scary and so because
there's potential judgement you get
scared and then you don't do the thing
teach yourself to do the thing if
filming in public sounds like a scary
thing to you like oh I couldn't do that
go do it go find the busiest street that
you can find and then go make a video
and here's the thing expect it to suck
you're not gonna be great the first time
you do something that's okay
I expect the stock expected to be the
worst video you've ever made and then
tie yourself on the back and say I did
it
rule number 60 take action the first
thing most people do after they make a
decision is a plan they strategize
they tinker they sing and it's the worst
thing you can do here's why you make a
bold decision you say I'm gonna change
my life
we often do this crazy amazing thing and
then you go home and you think of all
the ways that you can happen and you
start planning and strategizes amazing
you feel great and then you wake up
tomorrow and you're a different person
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and that person said you can't do that
you can't follow through on that who are
you to take on that big idea and then
nothing
nothing happens and so the solution
after you get immediate idea is actually
don't worry about planning even
imperfect action just action because you
need to build it into your nervous
system that you're the kind of person
who follows through because you need to
make some commitment so that by the time
you wake up tomorrow
you've committed to following through
that's the biggest problem I call the 2%
difference so what most people do is
they'll plan to 100% get an idea you got
a plan you gather the hope we got a plan
plan plan plan you know plan all the way
to the end and it's amazing and you
think about it it's such a great place
to live in as entrepreneurs as
perfectionist as over planners we love
living in that world don't worry about
planning to 100% instead find the 2%
difference what can you do right now
they get 2% of the way if you don't get
2% of the way immediately to action you
will never get to 100% of the way rule
number 17 find your one word I think
people struggle with goals because they
struggle it's self-awareness because
they don't know who they are and so
they're constantly adjusting the goals
that they have of themselves based off
what other people think of them and base
of what they see out in the media or an
Instagram or on YouTube they don't have
self-awareness you got to figure out
what your one word is what your most
important core value is who are you as a
human being I wrote a whole book on this
but just as a quick brainstorm
opportunity for you right now think
about what is your single most important
core value what is it we're gonna pick
one core values a human being what is it
to me it's belief I like believing in
people I need to believe in people I
hate negativity I hate toxic people I
hate the haters right I don't want to be
around people saying that you can't do
this I am the opposite I need to believe
and so already right they're already
having that awareness of what your one
word is what your who is when you figure
that out it allows you to make better
decisions it means that if you were in a
work environment if I was in a work
environment where people didn't believe
in each other I wouldn't I wouldn't be
able to handle it I would be frustrated
be upset I'd be angry and now I know why
because my one word is belief and so
what is your single most important core
value figure that out it's one of the
most important exercises you can ever do
in your life it's super helpful it's
valuable it's important you need to do
it otherwise you will never have clarity
over your goals rule number 80 do
difficult things self-love comes from
doing difficult things self-love comes
from doing things that you think are
beyond your comfort zone that you not
keep pull up doing and just getting up
and trying to do it that's when you love
yourself when something that's easy and
you win you actually don't feel that
great about yourself if you were to go
and run a race against three-year-olds
and you won great yeah you won you might
even post about on Instagram but you
don't love yourself you don't feel good
about yourself because you played small
because it was easy because you were
expected to win because it's inside your
comfort zone when you play inside your
comfort zone always you don't love
yourself that comes from doing difficult
things that's how you build respect
that's how you build credibility it's
how you build self-love for you forget
about how other people respect or look
at you it's how you feel about yourself
that's the game and that comes from
doing difficult things so if you ran a
race against three-year-olds and you won
great who cares
you don't feel great about yourself
because you were expected to win but if
you ran a race against Usain Bolt and he
ran backwards on one leg he would still
probably destroy you but you should feel
great about yourself because you did the
thing when it was hard to do the thing
you might have lost his same boat but
you got in the race against him that's
how you build self-love when you tie
your self-respect when you tie your
self-worth when you tie yourself love to
the effort that you put in on a daily
basis that's when you start to win when
you tie yourself love to winning to
getting results you lose when you tie
yourself up to how many likes you have
on Instagram or views or subscribers on
YouTube you lose this about the effort
are you putting in the effort every day
because if you are proud of your effort
on a daily basis I promise you you are
going to crush it but if you are only
proud of yourself when you win here's
what's gonna happen
you're only gonna take on small things
you're gonna play small your entire life
because you're only gonna take on
projects that you have a pretty high
chance of winning that because that's
how you have love for yourself and
that's the losing game because you're
capable of more you're capable of doing
a lot more stuff you keep a little
playing a bigger game you're capable of
having a bigger impact
you have to it's your duty it's your
duty to love yourself when you love
yourself you'll be able to spread that
more and help other people and so how do
you love yourself
it comes from doing difficult things it
comes from when your hearts beating like
crazy and you're scared and it's some
big project and you say I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try to do that scary thing I'm
gonna try to record a video in public
people may be watching you doesn't mean
your video has to be great [ __ ] so it's
gonna suck but you tried I usually feel
great about yourself
rule number 19 have big dreams people
aren't lazy they just don't have dreams
that inspire them they default to
thinking I'm a lazy person I don't have
ambitions I don't know what I want to do
in life I'm just I'm just a loser
no you just don't have a dream that
makes you want to go off and do
something and until you figure that out
you're gonna be in this constant cycle
of feeling like a loser it's one of the
most common questions that I get asked
on my IG streams I go live every single
day and Instagram at least right now
well I want my tour and every single day
I get asked some variation of Evan I'm
lazy how do I get out of it Evan I'm
procrastinating how do I get out of it
one you don't call yourself a lazy
person there's no such thing as a lazy
person if you are procrastinating or
you're being lazy right you are being
lazy doesn't mean that you are a lazy
person there's two reasons why you're
doing it there's two reasons why you are
being lazy one you don't have a dream
that's big enough you don't have some
that inspires you you don't want to get
out of bed in the morning if I was an
accountant I would be a really lazy
accountant I would hate my life not to
knock accounts it's just not for me if I
was a video editor I would be I would be
lazy I would hate my life I don't want
to be a video editor I don't want to be
an accountant actually there's most
things in the world that I don't want to
be and if you forced me to do that I
would be lazy that's 95 percent of
America
I think 95 percent of America wakes up
and drive to the job that they hate and
then they're lazy there but they have
dreams they have ambitions you have
Michael Jordan level talent it's
something you just have to find it and
so if you don't know what that thing is
then it's your duty to go off and
explore you test you try you see you say
yes to a lot of stuff like this is the
most important thing that you need to
figure out in your life if you don't
know what your dream is you have to go
off and try things
just like you won't get married until
you go on dates you won't get married to
an idea until you go on dates until you
try it until you say yes and the acid
test is did I like it don't want to go
back this is fill me up that I enjoy the
process of it can I see myself doing
this and having fun because when you're
having fun doing the work that's when it
will fill you up that's when you won't
be lazy and there has been times and all
your lives where you felt that we felt
the joy the energy the ambition the
drive and so you need to capture that
and say yes and find what it is that
your big dream is rule number 20
surround yourself with good people
you're trying to change yourself to fit
into a social circle because you feel
you're not good enough you feeling good
enough you feel you won't be accepted
otherwise you feel you have no friends
the reality is you're different you're
weird that's amazing that's great and
it's never been easier to find your
tribe it's never been easier to find
people who build you up who support you
who cheer you on
who wants similar things to you and
until you find that group you're always
gonna feel like an outcast you're always
gonna feel like a fake you're always
gonna feel like you're trying to impress
people who you don't like but what's
your alternative because you have no
friends otherwise and so here's a
process you can use to follow to help
you be around the right people and start
building the life you want step 1
eliminate negativity think about the
people in your life right now we just
make you feel low who suck your energy
who you don't feel good about yourself
when you're around
we just make you feel oh and you don't
want to be around them anymore her maybe
those are some friends that you grew up
with and that they're not your friends
anymore
and that's okay I think a lot of us stay
in relationships based out of
convenience just because you want to
elementary school with somebody doesn't
mean that you should still be their
friend now you're just in that
relationship out of convenience you guys
have grown apart and you need to accept
it if you're around negative people like
that or maybe it's your parents then
either limit your exposure to them or
cut off access completely you know if
it's a friend who's toxic don't be
around that person anymore if it's
people who make you feel less then don't
be around those people anymore if it's
your parents or it's a close friend that
you still have some connection to but
there's just one thing that when you
talk about makes you feel bad don't talk
about those things anymore if you're
talking to your parents and they don't
like your entrepreneurial aspirations
don't talk about that stuff anymore
put boundaries up because there's still
enough of a connection around other
things hopefully if not maybe you don't
want to be talking to those people but
if there's enough of a connection still
with your mom with your dad talk about
that stuff and put boundaries around
talking about your career because you
know what's gonna cause controversy
people to get upset and negativity so
step one is you need to eliminate the
people or limit access to you from the
people who are causing you to feel bad
about you there's no way you're gonna
create amazing things build an amazing
business if you're around negative
people who bring you down all the time
it's just not possible so step one
eliminate those people or limit access
step two now you've got this whole
you've got a gap in your schedule you've
got extra time now on your hands and now
what you want to do is fill it with
positivity and I see two paths here one
you want to start trying to hang out
with people who feel the same way you do
and so look for entrepreneur events look
for meetup groups look for conferences
that coming to your town I'm here making
this video in Las Vegas at every stop
along the tour that I've been doing over
the past X number of days 45 days or so
we got a 45 more days ahead it's been
amazing to see the connections that
people make by being in a room of other
successful entrepreneurs who have the
same mindset of wanting the guac and
accomplish something great
somebody just DM me two days ago of
people who met in my Los Angeles event
they had never known each other before
they met at my LA event and then they
went running together so they went
running and caught the sunrise together
in LA that's what I'm talking about when
you start going to events where you
start meeting people who feel the same
way you do want to build similar things
as you are it just lifts your energy so
much the finally holy cow there's other
people who believe the same thing I do I
want to hang around those people more
and so say yes look at what events are
happening in your city and go to them
some might be free some might be paid
depends on what your budget is but go to
them start meeting people say yes be
around that environment because you're
not getting that right now with your
parents your friends the circle that
surrounds you immediately you need to
step out and start hanging around these
people and start going to events maybe
you only meet one person at that event
that's okay that's a start
surround yourself with those people rule
number 21 find your one worry nobody
wants to work with somebody who does
have integrity but what is integrity
what is that
mean for you how do you find it how do
you know what you staying for for me it
all comes down to values when you
understand what you staying for is human
being when you know what your most
important core value is then you know
how to live with integrity and you know
how to build a business based around
integrity as well and so the process
that I go through is your one word I
wrote a book about it you can read it
you can pick it up and understand how
apply it to your business in your life
but at the core is figuring out if I had
to stand for one thing as a human being
what is that thing and so a quick
process let's go through this quick
exercise together you can pick up the
book later right now think about one who
is your favorite teacher growing up
you've had lots of teachers growing up
through high school university
elementary school who was your favorite
teacher it wasn't because they taught
you grade 10 math it was a reason what
was it who was the person and what was
it - what was your favorite movie
growing up pick your favorite movie and
why and then three who's your favorite
entrepreneur who's the person he looked
up to the most who did you learn the
most from who do you most want emulate
if I run through that scenario for
myself number one my favorite teachers
met I'm far growing up at my school
Crescent school she always believed in
me she always helped me she always
guided me she helped take me from being
a B student to A+ student in my final
year she may feel like it was possible
- my favorite movie is Seabiscuit it's
about this racehorse that's too small
and a jockey that's too big and an owner
that has no money and a trainer that's
down on his luck and they all seem to
come together to build this racehorse
that goes off and wins a whole bunch of
races and helps lift the nation based
off a true story I've seen that movie at
least thirty times three my favorite
entrepreneur is AP Giannini he started
Bank of America he was a guy who first
gave immigrants in America money as a
loan he lent money to people based off
of a handshake and a look in their eye
if you can imagine he gave Walt Disney
the money to have his first
feature-length cartoons everybody
thought he was crazy and so what's a
common thread through all that between
madam fire Seabiscuit AP Giannini this
may all seem totally disconnected
they're not if I had to write down three
characteristics this is what you should
do you write down your three names and
then you have three characteristics for
each one the
believe pops off the sheet for me I
think about all of them and belief comes
at my time far believed in me my other
teachers are really nice they really
helped me it was amazing but she really
helped move the needle because she
believed in me
Seabiscuit I've seen lots of movies I
love them all it's great but the the
idea of believe coming through that
racehorse
I love it it's a cheesy movie but I love
it and then a Puccini is a belief banker
let money the people on bet on them when
nobody else believed in them my one word
is belief as a result I've built my
entire business around it right my life
and my business a built around belief my
videos my newsletter my website my
speaking gigs the books that I write
everything I create it's not just a
strategy it's a way of living and that's
having integrity with yourself so why
don't I make a top 10 video series on
the stupidest things that people say
because it's anti belief because it's
negative my channel would actually be
bigger if I did the negative side of
things people would rather be
entertained and laugh at others then
educate themselves and get better people
would rather sit at home and watch four
hours of Netflix every night then go off
and spend four hours learning and try to
build a business they just would we'd
rather be entertained and educated but I
don't want to be in that business I
don't want to be in a negative business
I don't want to be in the hater business
because my one word is believed and so
that's having integrity with myself and
an integrity with you guys my audience
my customers the people that I work with
and so yes integrity is at the core of
everything if you don't have integrity
people do not want to work with you but
how do you figure out what that means of
course you're not gonna go lie to
somebody right of course stealing is
gonna be bad but what else how do you
get more specific the biggest problem is
lack of clarity people don't know what
they stand for and as a result you're
living up to other people's expectations
and versions where I want you to live
inside yourself I want you to be
standing on a rock when everybody else
is sending it on quicksand you have
clarity you have definiteness of purpose
and it starts with figuring out your one
word so you pick up the book or you can
go to that 3-step process
think about who your favorite teacher
wasn't
I write three words down for thinking
about what your favorite movie is and
why write three words down for it and
think about who your favorite
entrepreneur or hero is of all time and
why write three words down from it look
at what similar your one word will pop
off the page and now you know what
integrity means to you
rule number 22 attack judgment people
sabotage themselves because they care
too much what other people think you're
spending money that you don't have on
stupid things that you don't need
because you value what other people
think of you more than what you think of
you if you can't get out of that trap
you'll never build the lesson you want
you'll just constantly be in reaction
mode doing what other people expect of
you so I think you should attack
judgment I think it's good I think
whenever you feel that you were playing
small because of somebody else's opinion
of you then you have to go off and do
that thing you need to attack judgment I
think it's one of the greatest skills
that you can ever teach yourself one of
the greatest practice that you can do on
a daily basis I think we play small by
default as humans I think it's big in to
us I think because of our survival
characteristics of how we need to fit in
to society to win I think we play small
by default and so you need to learn to
attack judgment so here's an example
my agent Steve I was on the phone with
him and I was telling him about my new
employment routine you know I can't do
much for myself right now I broke my
neck I broke my upper back I had a
concussion in the early days when I
first fell and hit my head and and all I
can do is speak which is great for
making videos but I can't move I
couldn't put my pants on by myself I
couldn't do a lot of stuff by myself and
so my agent steve says you need to film
your new morning routine you need to
show your audience what you're going
through you need to do an Instagram live
and show us what's happening like really
I'm thinking to myself you want me to
show off me putting my pants on in the
morning I'm feeling subconscious I've
gained some weight because I haven't be
able to move around never made a video
in my underwear before you know all this
all of these thoughts going through my
head and because that's part of the
reason because I'm worried about your
judgement then I have to do it I have to
do it the next day right like ASAP
you have to go do the thing learn to
attack judgment because as long as you
play small because you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you you'll
never go off and do the crazy things
that you want to do your entrepreneur's
you want to go off and change the world
you want to do amazing things you've got
visionary ideas of things that you want
to go off and do that means you're gonna
attack the status quo there's a lot of
people who want to protect the status
quo a lot of people so you're gonna get
judged you're gonna get attacked you're
gonna get criticized because your ideas
are different
you're weird duck be proud of it and so
anytime you catch yourself playing small
worried about somebody else's opinion
learn to attack it rule number 23 take
immediate action as soon as you get that
idea while you're feeling bold while
you're feeling inspired to go off and
take some kind of action I call it the
two percent difference don't worry about
trying to get to 100 percent don't worry
about planning and strategizing and
figuring it out and thinking that's what
most of us do we get an idea you think
you start thinking right you plan how do
I get to that hundred percent
No you've lost because you're gonna wake
up tomorrow a different person because
you're gonna go home today plan plan
plan and wake up tomorrow a different
person and then not take action because
you're scared because your brain will
start talking you down from that crazy
big idea your brain will talk you down
from going off to living your truth
that's what's gonna happen that's what
always happens and so while you're
feeling the energy in the momentum you
got to take some action instead of
planning how to get to 100% of the way
you take action immediately on getting
2% of the way 2% the 2% difference go
from 0 to 2% if you can't take a medium
momentum to get in 2% of the way you
will never get 200% you have an idea to
make a youtube channel great go make
your video right now today ASAP the 2%
difference make your first video right
now with your cell phone what most
people will do is start researching
right what am I gonna talk about what am
I gonna wear what's my hair gonna look
like how what camera do I need to get
what what phone do I need to get right
what's my lighting gonna be what
microphone think think think think think
think think think think and then never
do because you're perfectionist
you're gonna perfect your way of ever
living your truth the beginning is messy
it's supposed to be messy so often get
you 2% difference towards finding and
living your truth quick example my story
I'm hearing Albuquerque New Mexico right
now I was walking down a beautiful
or Day last year and I decided that I
was gonna take Nina to every city in
North America with a million plus people
every city in North America 1 million
plus people that was my decision great
what's my first step action the 2%
difference so it's not here's what most
people do it's not go home and research
how many cities there are it's not go
home and make a plan for how we're gonna
do this there's lots of reasons why it's
not gonna work Nina still had a
full-time job I had no idea how many
cities there were I had no idea what the
next step was gonna be just do something
immediate action and so I thought right
away
five seconds later here's my goal great
five seconds later this weekend let's
hit one city Boston Nina never been to
Boston so I thought Boston was the
closest city to Toronto
it wasn't Pittsburgh at Sheila's and on
my tour the people in Pittsburgh told me
they'd let me know the Pittsburgh is
closer but it doesn't matter this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston it was
a Wednesday that I decided and on Friday
night we were leaving for Boston boom I
hit 2% just 50 cities we're gonna hit
one this weekend we're gonna get 2% of
the way done on the way back from Boston
we decided to do this tour that I'm on
right now and now we're gonna hit 50% of
the cities on my list momentum that's
the thing that's missing momentum
because you're trying to be perfect
you're trying to fully understand your
truth but you can't sink your way
through your truth you have to
experience it and feel it and the
starting point is a 2% difference so
take whatever idea that you have and
train yourselves I want to burn this
into your nervous system this is one of
the most important things you can do up
all time as soon as you get an idea
action idea action idea action the more
you can shortcut that that window
instead of taking a week to take action
or daily take action immediate idea boom
some kind of 2% action and expected not
to be perfect expecting that to be the
best plan my plan was wrong right
Pittsburgh was closer in my head I
thought it was Boston we went down the
wrong path but the momentum is what
matters and now we're 50% of the way and
now I'm gonna close that gap and get the
rest of it the 2% difference rule number
24 endure hardships in an entrepreneur
is one of the hardest things you'll ever
do in your life
whether you go all-in financially or not
you're gonna go all-in emotionally and a
lot of people they can't cut it they
can't get the cows as fast enough and so
they quit
that's gonna be one of the biggest tests
for you as you get off and build your
business do you have the mental
fortitude to keep going keep driving
keep building your business in the face
of all obstacles
it's the ultimate endurance test it's
the ultimate test to see what you're
made of when I first started my company
I knew it was gonna be hard but it
didn't think it would be this hard you
never think is gonna be as hard as it
actually is I was making $300 a month
I turned down $100,000 a year six
figures working for my dream job company
to make three hundred dollars a month
and own 30% of a company
I eat beans for lunch every day the same
bean salad for lunch mixed beans with
olive oil and herbs and garlic in salt a
little pepper because it was cheap and
it would fill me up and when I wanted to
splurge I would go to the store and get
the the chunky Campbell's soup clam
chowder there's a little bit more
expensive but also fill me up when we
went to celebrate a win we would go to
McDonald's and get a McDonald's french
fries large fries and share between the
three of us because that's what we could
afford couldn't afford the whole meal
and even to this day the smell of
McDonald's french fries means victory
for me it's the most unhealthy thing in
the world but it still means victory for
me I made it even harder on myself and
that I isolated myself and I didn't tell
my friends that I was struggling I had
to pick one thing a month that I could
go to one friendly you know social pizza
and beer kind of thing per month because
at 20 bucks I didn't have because I'm
only making 300 a month so I isolated
myself I turned inwards I was too
embarrassed and ashamed to tell my
friends who are off making 80 hundred
thousand dollars a year starting salary
at the University and I'm making three
hundred bucks a month I was too
embarrassed and ashamed and so I told
them I'm hustling I'm living the
entrepreneur life you know I'm grinding
but really I was struggling I had no
idea what I was doing this thing was
tearing me apart and it got to the point
where I actually quit on my business
partner I told him I quit it's easy to
quit on something
and not get results when you know that
you're not putting in the effort but I
was putting in the effort every single
day showing up to my business partners
dining room table because everything
else is too small in his place to fit us
putting in the effort every single day
trying to build and grow this business
and just it wasn't working I felt
worthless as a human like why are we not
getting results when will we start the
Kiat results and it was fed up and tired
and I told my quit like I need to find a
way to to be useful to feel valuable as
a human and so I told my quit and then I
woke up the next day and said I can't
quit because I haven't given it
everything that I've got and so there's
a two-step process that saved me that I
hope will save you if you're feeling
down and out and it's tough and you're
not getting results the first step is
use regret to fuel you I imagine my life
at 100 looking back on this moment
saying what I regret quitting it's very
rarely the things that you do that you
regret it's the things that you don't do
so what I regret not continuing what I
regret not giving it my all and I try to
adopt the mantra that I would rather no
one fail to not know I would rather know
and fail than not know so I had to see
this through even if the answer was
total failure even if it never worked
out I had to see it all the way through
just to know because otherwise that
regret would eat me up and so number one
use regret when you're struggling when
it's not working out when you're not
getting results imagine yourself being a
hundred years old looking back and
saying if you quit now if you stop if
you don't keep going will you regret it
number two is model success the next
thing that saved me was I asked myself
that next morning after I quit and then
decided I need to go back because I
can't live with regret I asked myself
who has done this before who has built
the software company up I can't be the
only person who tried to do this and I
looked at Bill Gates who started
Microsoft and not how he makes an extra
million dollars now but zero to one how
did he do that how did that happen
I studied his success I modeled the
success I applied it to my company and
pretty shortly got my first deal for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars
that may not seem like a lot of money
but to me back then
it was it was hitting the lottery I'm
making 300 bucks a month now I just made
a deal for thirteen and a half thousand
that was hope that was real that was
putting my money my bank account you
know that was be able to have a full
meal at McDonald's and more important it
gave me a model that I could do again
and again and again it closed another
deal and another deal and another deal
and her business started to take off and
ever since that was 20 years ago I use
the same two-step process
rule number 25 and do it rule number 25
do the difficult things you need to do
things that make you feel proud when
things get difficult most people will
find really smart ways to talk
themselves down from doing difficult
things and the smarter you are the
better excuse slash reason you have to
not to do the thing but until you own up
and go after and chase down difficult
things you'll never be proud of yourself
and you'll never accomplish the big
goals you have for yourself so I'm here
on my tour I committed to doing 90 days
23 cities a new city basically every
four days and I broke my neck two weeks
ago I broke my neck in Denver and I had
to cancel my Denver event cuz it was in
the hospital but then I got up when I
did a short version of my Kansas City
event and then I got up and did a full
version of a Minnesota event and then I
got up and did a full version of my
Milwaukee event here last night
I wanted to work that makes you feel
proud it's difficult it's hard everybody
would have understood if I cancelled
right if I say guys sorry I broke my
neck broke my back have a concussion
three staples in my head I can't keep
going everybody would have understood
but I wouldn't have felt proud and that
needs to be your asset test it's not
what other people think about you it's
not what other people let you off the
hook it's not what other people think
that you're great it's what do you think
about yourself are you proud of the
decisions that you make in your life
rule a six stop comparing to others
you're constantly comparing your version
of success your version of life compared
to what you see out
there are other people's versions you
look at what they're doing the Instagram
when YouTube but in social media and in
the tabloids and in the you know you
look at those people you say that's the
life that I want have you no confidence
in your own version of your life that's
a problem that's what you need to fix I
often get asked on my tour hey Evan
what's the perfect morning routine like
what do you do ever you wanted to get
yourself started what I do almost
doesn't matter
stop comparing yourself to me we have
different versions of what success and
balance look like I look at what the
rock does for example he needs to work
out for four hours a day he needs to do
cardio twice he needs to do weights
twice when he has to be on a movie set
by 9:00 a.m. he wakes up at 4:00 goes
and works out for four hours comes back
showers and then goes to his set and
when he's shooting the movie he'll sleep
five hours a night I think that's crazy
I don't look like the rock there's a
reason we have different priorities
different version of balance but this is
the problem because you want to work out
like the rock and you want to be a good
dad like this person and you want to be
a good entrepreneur like this person a
visionary like this person and you're
constantly judging your version of your
life versus somebody else's it's
unobtainable it's not possible because
there's no self confidence in what you
already have it doesn't matter what I do
in the morning it doesn't matter what
the rock does in the morning what
matters is you start your day with the
thing that makes you come alive if you
started your day with the thing that
made you feel bold and self-confident
every single day your life would look
dramatically different one year from
today than where you are right now it
just would but what that thing is is
different for everybody we have
different goals we have different things
that drive and move us and so it starts
with having the self-awareness to figure
out what it is that you want and then
the self-confidence to believe in it
enough that when you see something shiny
over here you're not swayed by didn't
think that you sucked because this
person's crushing it in a different
field the rule number 27 bring value I
think most people are confused about
money most people don't have a healthy
relationship with money there are the
people who think that money is
everything the money is the only
important thing in the world then you
need to chase it down and is your duty
and responsibilities and obligations
like it's number one the person walking
into my
house my place a business that's my next
suit that's my next payment that's my
next whatever it's only focused on money
and there's other people who think money
is the root of all evil and that money
is a bad thing money is a tool money
helps you get a lot of things done money
helps you go places money helps you
accomplish your mission money needs to
be in your top five it's just not number
one money needs to be in your top five
if money does not become important at
some point to you if it's not in your
top five priorities you'll never make
money and you'll always be by yourself
struggling trying to figure out how to
make something work but it's not number
one either
if you put money above all else you'll
end up doing a lot of work that you hate
and you never get good at it just
because you're chasing opportunities
this is a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs fail you're just chasing
the hottest thing for this year that you
don't have a passion or interest in and
then you lose because the people who
love that destroy you when I first
started doing this helping entrepreneurs
I never thought I was gonna make money
my first speaking gig my first option to
help people was in Canada in my hometown
of Toronto was at a YMCA it was a free
event they had an entre nursery program
they asked me to come and speak to their
members it was free I wasn't getting
paid to do it just wanted to help out I
just sold my business I wanted to give
back I was saying yes to everything that
she didn't even know what I want to do
next and so I show up and this is big
room full of chairs and only three
people show up to that first event only
three people and as soon as I walked in
the room I saw three people my heart
sank I felt like I'm never gonna be able
to make anything from this if only three
people show up to a free event how am I
ever gonna make money from it I didn't
know but I gave my best to those three
people I know that I helped those three
people and had an impact on their lives
we then went for coffee afterwards and
continued the conversation I know that I
helped them and it filled my soul and
had to find a way to keep doing it I
knew I had to find a way to keep doing
it even if I never made money and so I
did I kept doing speaking gigs I did my
website I did my YouTube channel and
slowly slowly slowly slowly it started
to come in as I figure it out
the second key important piece which is
figuring out how to bring value to other
people when you find something that you
love doing and you combine it with how
it brings value to other people that's
when you start making money it was
something that you just loved doing
but nobody else likes it there's zero
value to anybody else you have a hobby
you have a hobby if you're only chasing
stuff that people like in need but you
don't like doing it you're never gonna
get great at it you might make a little
bit of money but you're never gonna get
great at it you're never gonna be
all-time you're never going to build a
huge business and so it's that
combination of doing work that you love
doing and mix it with where does an
opportunity that people need it's a
problem that you are solving mix those
things together
you have a super successful business
rule number 28 start small entrepreneurs
don't have to be giant risk takers some
entrepreneurs have to go all-in it's the
only way they can operate earn the boats
have no plan B have no escape no
parachute all in one way trip it's the
only way they operate but there's tons
of successful entrepreneurs who win by
building sustained momentum by taking
small successful risks over and over
again but never put it all on the line I
love small starts I love finally ways to
get started on tons of different ideas
and seeing what sticks and where my
heart lies and following those through
but I'll never put in tons of money
before putting in the effort and energy
to see if I'd love it to try to get
results so I look at YouTube as an
example it's 10 years of having this
channel it's wow that's crazy
I started it just as an experiment I had
a successful website I had eight people
on my team building up this new web
business that I was a part of and I just
wanted to try YouTube I wanted to make
visual content I love learning from
successful people and so I wanted to
tell those stories in the visual way
that plus people kept asking me
questions I'd sold my company and so
they asked me questions Evan how do I do
this how do I do that great so I would
make videos answering questions for
people but I did it all myself right
like I got some friends to volunteer to
help me make some of my really
and then everything was me I had money I
sold my business I had a team working on
my website but I was doing this little
skunkworks project all by myself just to
go just make it happen just to see just
to see if I liked it see if I can build
some momentum and so I researched and I
edited and I filmed I did everything and
as it started then to make some money
then I could invest that money back into
my business and then it slowly built up
to what we're we're at right now between
on be the chief goal officer you need to
be people's chief goal officer if you
want to move them into action if you
want them to win you have to speak to
them in their language and the things
that they care about the worst advice
you could give somebody is what you
would do if you treat everybody who
works with you and for you like the way
you would be treated you're gonna lose
forever you're never gonna build the
organization you want because people
have different goals and it's your job
to understand what they are so I'm doing
this tour right now 90 days 23 cities I
often get asked by people
hey Evan what book should I read what
video do you recommend from your channel
for an entrepreneur I'm 6,000 videos the
worst advice I could give is to give a
generic answer the worst advice I could
give is to one that I would watch like
here's a video that I loved the most for
me to give a good answer to you I need
to know your problem I need to be your
chief goal officer I need to understand
what you're struggling with I could give
you the greatest book recommendation of
all time but if it's not the thing that
you care about right now it's not gonna
serve you and so before you give advice
before you try to help somebody else out
be their chief goal officer there's two
ways to do it understand their who and
understand their why their who is their
most important one word core value and
they're why is their purpose and their
purpose comes from their pain so look at
their who I'll use an example with Alex
who who runs trying to dance salsa for
me his who is belong his one word is
belong he wants to create a place where
people feel like they belong it's the
one word for him it's a one word for TBS
I know that's what he really cares about
for me belonging doesn't really matter
if I don't feel like I belong in a room
I'm not bothered by it I don't
where the people think of me it's it's
so lowdown on my list of priorities and
values of what I personally care about
but for him it's number one he wants to
make people feel like they belong that's
his one word most important core value
that's his who so I understand a little
bit more about him I understand how to
push him the next is your why your
purpose comes from your pain for him he
struggled so much in in making friends
and feeling accepted he had super sweaty
hands and when he held the girl's hand
he would slide out because he sweat so
much and it tied into him never feeling
like he belong and so this is now his
purpose for life is to help other people
feel like they belong that there's a
space for them to come to and feel like
they belong his favorite movie of all
time is Hercules the Disney movie the
cartoon were in that song he says
something about a place where you belong
and when he hears that song he cries
great this is Alex right I might play
that song for myself and think that's a
good song I'm gonna play that song for
somebody else and they hate that song
screw Hercules amazing everybody's
different you need to be their chief
goal officer so if I'm talking out and
trying to motivate and push him and have
him build an amazing company that he's
proud of I'm gonna use words like belong
I'm gonna use movie references like
Hercules I'm gonna talk about creating a
place where people can come together and
feel like they're finally accepted
because that's at the core what he's all
about that's me being his chief goal
officer and so you need to do that for
everybody on your team you need to do
that for every customer that you work
with stop treating everybody the same
way there's the classic rule of do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you and that's great and that's treating
people with compassion and care and
kindness but everybody's motivated by
different things and if you can only
treat people one way the way that you
would like to be treated
you're gonna only have success with a
very narrow band of people a very narrow
band of customers a very narrow band of
employees a very narrow band of partners
you're gonna stay in this tiny little
lane your entire life and never build a
huge company but if you can learn to be
somebody's chief goal officer if you can
learn to understand what drives that
moves and pushes them what their who is
what their why is why they're here what
they're trying to accomplish you start
building an eight-lane superhighway
and you can build a company that can
take over the world really we're 30
enjoy the process I'm much more wanna
enjoy the process of the work that I'm
doing then then getting the end result
when I've made my youtube channel and we
hit a million subscribers everybody's
asking me what's the celebration what
are you guys gonna do what's the plan oh
I didn't need to celebrate we ended up
doing a livestream because I wanted to
celebrate with you guys because it was
important for you but for me I don't I
don't care to celebrate like let's keep
going I love this is the celebration
making these videos is the celebration
not getting the plaque not crossing a
million NOK route XYZ me results matter
of course but the process enjoying the
process and doing difficult things is
how I get myself to take action not
visualizing the end result
rule number 31 love the struggle we need
to learn to love struggle you need to
learn to tell yourself that the struggle
is the best because if you're not
chasing down difficult things you're
living a life so safe so inside your
comfort zone that you're never happy I
had a woman come out to my event last
night here in Milwaukee and I gave her
some advice on how to build their
business and she said wow that sounds so
hard yeah teach yourself that you're the
kind of person who does hard things I
love hacks
I love shortcuts I love optimizing I
love it it's amazing it's the best and I
love doing difficult things otherwise
you stay inside your comfort zone and
you only do the things that you feel
safe to do and then you hate your life
if you're not pushing up against your
comfort zone if you're not stretching
further if you're not going into the
struggle you hate your life the people
who are the most fulfilled are the ones
who are off pushing the envelope doing
difficult things I look at this I broke
my neck in Denver right I broke my neck
I'll continue to tour we still had I
don't know five or six more stops that
we had to make almost a month of touring
you still had to go off into the tour I
cancelled one stop they made in a short
version in Kansas City
and then I did all the way through we're
still going full three hours I had to
still make videos write videos still
have to go up last week I was still
suffering from a concussion so I hit my
head on on the on the baseboard cut my
head open
three staples in the back of my head
broke my neck broke my upper back got a
concussion still gonna make videos right
I still have to make videos I love it
because it's in the difficult times that
you show yourself what you're made of
when it's easy and you win you don't
care if you win every seconds
three-year-olds who cares but if you go
up and race against it was saying both
and he beats you backwards on one leg
you're still pumped cuz you're caught in
the race against the same fold the self
pride the self-respect the confidence
the growth comes from doing things that
you struggle with not from always doing
the easy thing you hate your life if
you're just doing the easy thing
rule number 32 help your customers I
think you need to be your customers
chief goal officer I think if you want
to win in business you have to
understand your customers you become
their chief goal officer if you aren't
accomplish your goals the best way to
get there is help your customers
accomplish their goals if you're helping
them you're solving problems guess what
you're gonna make money they're gonna
pay you to do it now you have to combine
what they want right you're the chief
goal officer this is what they want and
combine it with what you love doing can
you help them solve that problem are you
the person to solve it or do you want to
refer somebody else off to them to solve
that problem when you can mix those
things together the thing you absolutely
love doing with what the customer so
desperately wants that's when you start
to win rule number 33 don't chase money
chasing money makes you do stupid things
money is important it has to be in your
top 5 it just can't be number 1 you're
heroes the people that you look up to
the people that you want to be like the
ones who went off and change the world a
meet a lot of money in the process they
had a mission money was not number one
for them look at whoever you look up to
respect love admire your heroes
understand them look at their story
money is in their top 5 but it's not
number 1 and so when you go up against
somebody like that when you go up
against somebody who's chasing
their purpose and you're coming into the
industry because you think it's a hot
opportunity for this year
they're gonna question you will always
get crushed by the person who loves the
thing if for you it's just an
opportunity and so that's why chase some
money makes you do stupid things you get
into an industry because you think it's
gonna be a hot chance for you but you're
gonna lose because you don't love it the
people who love it will always win and
so it's much better for you to go off
and chase down something you love and
make money in the process of doing that
thing it's why the number one rule for
success that comes up the most
consistently across all the people that
I profiled across all different kinds of
industries and backgrounds is you have
to love what you do
rule number 34 be patient with the
results you're not in a big enough hurry
because you don't view patience and
impatience properly you were trained and
conditioned with the perspective that
does not serve you today we're gonna
break that we're gonna set you free so
you can start hitting your goals a lot
faster
most people are patient with themselves
but impatient with the results I'll see
ended up again you're patient with
yourself but you're impatient with the
results you want the results to happen
right away you're impatient like when am
I gonna get these results but you're
patient with yourself you'll give
yourself a break you'll let yourself
down like I'll do that tomorrow you're
patient with yourself but you're
impatient with the results I want you to
flip it this is the perspective ship
that if you understand and make in your
business your entire life will change
you need to flip it you want to be
patient with the results and impatient
with yourself you want to be patient
with the results and impatient with
yourself know that the results that
you're after will take time you're
chasing down big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things go take some time for that to
happen but the impatience you need to
put on a daily basis is on yourself did
you do the most you can do today and
every single day to move a little bit
closer to achieving your goals so look
at my business an example my next goal
is to hit 10 million subscribers on my
main youtube channel that's a big goal
it's gonna take me a while to get there
right it's not gonna happen tomorrow no
matter how much work I put in no matter
what I do it's not happening tomorrow
it's gonna take some time I get that I'm
patient with that and I'm insanely
impatient with myself it's like what can
I do more today to get me closer to that
goal
rule number 35 find your core values if
you don't get this right your business
will fail it's not just about what you
love doing in the skillsets you have
it's about having similar core values as
the people that you bring on board you
need to know what your who is you need
to know what you stand for as a human
being you need to know what your mission
is and bring people on board who have
similar core values this is where so
many entrepreneurs fail if you only do a
self-assessment and say well I'm good at
this I'm gonna be the technician I'm
gonna be the artist I'm gonna be the
coder I'm gonna be the one doing all of
the actual work and I need to partner up
with somebody who's a business person
who's gonna be doing the deals in the
media and raising the capital talking to
investors and doing the sales pitches
it's not enough to say well I'm good at
this and you're good at this so let's
get together and that's what so many
people do that's why so many business
partnerships fail because you're just
looking at it on paper you just see well
they have the skill sets I don't have
great let's work together boom we're in
business
and often times entrepreneurs will then
say hey Walt let's do 50/50 right you're
bringing this I'm running there so here
we go 50/50 partnership and for those
who've been through it before you know
how much of a disaster that can be
because everything looks good on paper
but you can't make a decision just based
off of paper it's like going to a dating
web site and put in your ideal person
and then deciding to marry that person
without ever going on a date
it's about core values why do things
fall apart because you don't share the
same core values and a lot of times you
need to know what your own core value is
to start with so you figure out your one
word your most important core value
that's the starting point you have to
figure it out and it'll serve you not
just for your business but for any
relationship for life this is what you
stand for is a human and then you want
to attract people who not just have the
skill set
in the desire but the same core value
because you know what the skill set is
actually easier to teach than the core
value to make somebody change their
beliefs I don't know how to do it it's
crazy it's ridiculous to give somebody a
new skill set is way easier to teach
rule number 36 chase the yes he'll
decisions no hell yes rule number 36
chase - hell yes decisions you spend too
much time focused on the small decisions
that don't actually move your business
forward instead of focusing on the ones
that you actually get pumped for so look
at my business I look at my youtube
channel my goal right now was I want to
get 10 million subscribers on my main
YouTube channel I'm excited I'm pumped
let's go do it I'm chasing it down and
I've got a list of ideas a giant list of
ideas
and as people watch my videos and I talk
to my friends about it they give me more
ideas and the list just keeps building
is this something that you can resonate
with that list of ideas just keeps
growing and growing and growing
I keep it in Evernote I don't know where
you write down your ideas the problem is
most of those ideas they could be
fantastic strategic ideas that just
makes total logical sense to do those
things but I look at them in to like
yeah okay yeah hmm
it's okay yeah that's good we should do
that yeah yeah if you're not emotionally
attached to what you won't have massive
success doing it it has to be a hell yes
and so when the my tour came along the
idea of doing a 23 City 90-day tour I
don't have time for it logically makes
no sense I don't have time to do this
it's crazy look at this giant list of
ideas I have to do hell yes I want to do
then and off we go
23 cities 90 days I just got back hey
back in my entrepreneur Lane setting
here for those of you who are oh gee
from my channel you have to chase the
hell yes decisions and stop getting
stuck in the mess and okay land rule
number 37 be strategic I think people
should quit and way more than they
actually do you stayed in a business for
too long you stayed with an employee for
too long you stayed in a relationship
for too long you should have quit
them years ago but because you've tied
your self-worth to winning your pride
prevents you from quitting staying in
something even if you hate your life
just staying in it means that you don't
have to admit to yourself that you're a
quitter and so you stay but you're
actually losing in my first business was
a software company I struggled with this
I was 19 I thought I was gonna make it
rich and be a super successful
entrepreneur and I sucked and I
struggled I was making $300 a month and
and I didn't know what to do I was too
embarrassed to tell my friends that I
had no money and I couldn't go out with
them and that the 20 bucks of Pizza beer
was too expensive for me and it took me
to a rock-bottom moment until I could
actually be strategic and realized that
I needed to change what happened was I
told my partner that I quit
we were working long hours like this is
my entire life working on this business
crazy hours and just not getting results
and so I'd finally had enough I felt
like a worthless human being I called my
business partner said I'm out like I
have to go do something where I feel
like I can contribute to the world
somehow and so I told my quit and then I
hung up the phone and I and I cried I
cried my face off and I woke up the next
day and said I can't quit on this yet
because I would regret it if I did but I
have to find another way to stain like
this is taking too much out of me and so
I asked myself who had done this who had
built the software couple before and I
looked at Bill Gates and how he started
Microsoft and I used that his strategies
to help my company grow and then we
stood it away and then we started to
make money he started to get some
customers a client and then she sold my
business but I almost didn't come back
to it if I hadn't been strategic in that
moment and said okay I can't quit
because I'm gonna regret this decision
for the rest of my life
if I didn't step out of that emotional
zone just for a few seconds to realize I
need to keep going and look at who had
done this before I wouldn't be where I'm
at today
rule number 38 have a cause having a
cause will make you feel like a
superhero it will allow you to do things
you never thought you'd do
gave you the courage you'd never thought
you'd have all of your heroes had a
cause and if you want to stop selling
sugar water and change the world it's
time to find yours
I love the Steve Jobs story I'm a huge
fan of Steve I have his poster on my
wall as one of five people that look up
to on a daily basis but one of the
things that I really find most valuable
about having a cause is it can allow you
to have the courage to be the
evangelical person even if it's not
naturally who you are I look at Steve
Jobs and I see someone who is naturally
talented who's a great salesperson who
has the gift of gab who loves being in
the spotlight who is that person who
likes being up front and center and so
it's easy to go off and be that person
now you combine that with a cause and
you get a company like Apple but having
a cause can make you evangelical even if
you are introvert and shy and don't like
the spotlight I know because I'm talking
about myself I am an introvert I don't
like talking to people I don't talk to
the person next to me on the airplane
being in front of the camera makes me
nervous being in front of a giant
audience makes me shy had much rather be
at the back of a room than be the center
of attention one of the things they used
to fight the most with my agent about
was he would say that everything you
don't want to be famous that's a problem
like yeah I don't want to be famous it's
not about me it's about the cause and
recently it started to sink in that by
me becoming more famous I could spread
the message more but it's one of the
biggest things that we kept fighting
over because I don't crave the limelight
where a lot of people they absolutely
have to have it but when you have a car
that forces you to the front I make
videos because I want to help
entrepreneurs I make videos because I
struggled so much your purpose comes in
your pain I struggled somebody started
my business I want to make the path a
little bit easier for the next
generation of people coming through I'm
making videos and content and speeches
for the 19 year old version of myself
that needed to hear this stuff and so I
feel it's my responsibility it's my
obligation I have to do it and it forces
me out into stages that normally I would
say you're crazy I'm on this tour right
now right I gave up a quarter of my year
90 days they hit 23 cities and do the
thing that I'm most afraid to do which
is get up and potentially disappoint
people every four days by do
another event and I kept going even
though I broke my neck I broke my neck
three weeks ago in Denver and and we
kept going I only canceled one event
completely and it just got up and kept
going and so having that cause feeling
like the work that you do is important
and meaningful is the whole thing
rule number 39 do what makes you proud
the problem is you're not proud of
yourself you might post about some
accomplishment you've done on Facebook
or Instagram but when it's you by
yourself all alone
deep down you're not actually proud of
yourself so why where does that come
from it's because you've taught yourself
that you set goals and you don't
consistently follow through so now when
you set a new goal for yourself you
don't believe that you're actually gonna
follow through and that continues to
cycle on and on and spirals down into
you not being proud of yourself we need
to change that today so it starts with
this when you set a goal you have to
follow through the only acceptable
reason for not following through is you
being proud of yourself are you proud of
the reason why you didn't follow through
so a couple examples when I started my
tour the very first stop the pre tour
stop was Boston I had a goal at that
time that I was gonna run 30 minutes of
cardio every day we drove the Boston I
drove the whole way didn't sleep a wink
got in at 2:00 in the morning I hadn't
done my cardio what do we need to do I
need to do my cardio why because I told
myself I've committed to doing 30
minutes of cardio every single day the
cardio was the worst cardiovert I'm
barely moving right just kind of half
eyes closed trying to struggle my way
through the 30 minutes health-wise I
burnt zero calories it would have been
better for me to go to sleep
mentally though for the mindset I'm
pumped it's when it's hard and you do
the thing that you actually build your
self-respect your self pride your
self-love your self-confidence when it's
easy and you win you could post a butter
on Instagram congratulations but you
don't feel great about yourself because
it was easy but when it's hard and you
try that's when you start building self
respect self accountability self pride
that's where it comes from
and so in Boston I woke up the next day
and I was tired and I had a sluggish
hard day trying to get through it which
was not great for my body but mentally
I'm pumped like I did the thing when it
was difficult if I just went to bed at
what I had to ask myself am i proud of
the reason why I'm not doing this
although people would let me off the
hook I'm sure the people I went down
with Ninon my wife Danny my camera guy
would have said it's okay go to sleep
it's 2:00 in the morning you drove all
this way so it's a strange day it's not
a typical day you have every reason in
the world not to do it people will let
you off the hook all the time because
they don't hold themselves to high
standards and then they infect you with
their lower standards I would not have
been proud of myself if I didn't do my
run even though the results sucked it's
the effort that's where the pride comes
from rule number 40 just be yourself
just be yourself is one of the most
common pieces of advice that you hear
from successful people just be yourself
everyone else is taken
just be yourself your unique snowflake
yes amazing but how how do I do it how
do I find it and once I find it how do I
have the confidence to actually live it
how give me the hell you're in luck I'm
gonna give you the three-step process on
how to actually find out who you are and
have the confidence to live it we're
gonna go through three steps whoo why
have your whoo your why your have you
figure that out you're set up for life
it's one of the most powerful exercises
you will ever do in your life let's dig
in number one your hoop your who is your
one word most important core value what
is your single most important core value
mine is belief when you understand what
you're saying for you're less likely to
be pulled in other people's directions
so quick tips on how to find it what's
your favorite movie of all time
mine is Seabiscuit it's about this horse
that's too small and a jockey too big
and a owner that has no money and they
find each other and they start winning a
whole bunch of races right what's your
favorite song of all time who is your
favorite teacher of all time and why and
if you look at all these things that you
have loved it wasn't because mrs. Jones
taught you math in grade eight it's
because of the characteristic there's a
common thread between all the things
that you love that make you happy that's
your one word that's your most important
core value when you figure that out
now you can live a life on purpose and
bring those things to you so for me
believe I'm not gonna make a video
that's trashing somebody I'm not gonna
make a top 10 stupidest things that this
person ever said even though it might
make me more money even though it might
bring me more subscribers even though it
might get me more attention I don't want
to do it because it's anti believe and
knowing that knowing what I stand for
then makes it easy to put that shield up
to say no I don't care about your
opinion I don't care that you think I
should go do that thing I know what I
stand for it gives you a rock to stand
on where most people are sitting on
click saying if you girl your whoo step
2 is to figure out your why that's your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain think about the most painful moment
in your life your purpose for life will
be to help other people who are
currently experienced in that pain to
find somebody who is going through the
thing that causes you the most pain in
your life will lift you up and give you
so much joy I can't explain it
and you're who and you're why your one
word and your purpose are for life so
for me my why my purpose is helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur because I turned
down huge jobs to make 300 bucks a month
and earn 30 percent of a company and I
hated my life like I felt worthless I
felt like I wasn't giving any value it
sucked I eventually made it through and
I want to help entrepreneurs because I
remember struggling so much as an
entrepreneur I don't want people to have
to struggle the same way that I
struggled and so my one word is believe
I could believe in anybody I could
believe in lots of people everybody
needs believing in but I love helping
entrepreneurs more because that's where
I came from because that was my biggest
struggle my biggest pain and so think
about your most painful moment of all
time helping the people who are
currently experiencing the thing that
you went through is gonna be the thing
that will fill you up for life you're
who and you're why or for life they will
never change they're with you for life
and so it's worth going through that
thought experiment to find it because
most of America has no idea what they
stand for and what their purpose is sep
3 is your how now it's figuring out how
did you get through the thing that you
went through right I struggled as an
entrepreneur the thing that saved my
business was modeling Bill Gates how did
Bill Gates build a software company
that's what I had I had a software
company I wasn't working I copied Bill
Gates's strategies I plotted to hide
has had my first sale shortly after for
13 and a half thousand dollars I mean it
seemed like a lot of money but for me it
was it was money it was money was bank
like holy cow something's actually
working and so ever since then that was
when I was in nineteen twenty years old
ever since then when I ever I don't know
what to do i model success I modeled
Bill Gates success and put that to my
company I had success and so what have I
done for the past twenty years made main
content made videos look at my channel
profiling different successful
entrepreneurs to model their success the
path that I use to get out of the hole
is the path that then I teach the path
that you use to get out of the hole that
you're in becomes a path that you teach
it's a it's a system it's replicatable
you could teach other people how to do
it because a lot of the people who are
struggling with a thing that you
struggled with they never find their way
out you can help them by showing them
the path that you took and so you're who
you're why you're how when you figure
that out that's how you are yourself and
now you've got this amazing rock to
stand on when other people think you
should go do something else
you don't care it doesn't hit you it
bounces off to because you're confident
in yourself and so yes be yourself and
it's gonna come up over and over and
over and over again look at the top tens
look at the impresses look at all the
videos look at the interviews look at
the people that you look up to they're
all gonna say just be yourself by the
how this is the process if you go you're
who figure out your why figure out your
have go through those three steps and
you're set up for life and I'm so pumped
to see the journey that you go on rule
number 41 take risks most people are so
afraid of losing that they don't even
try you'd rather stay average because
going for greatness means you might fail
adopt this mindset it's better to know
and to fail than not to know all of your
heroes failed on their path to success
and if you are unwilling to risk failure
for greatness you will stay on your
exact same path that you're on right now
so I was recently faced with an
impossible choice where I didn't know
the outcome where two people who I
respected told me opposite bits of
advice and it was around splitting up my
youtube channel I
had my youtube-channel I mean one for
over 10 years it's crazy ten years of
creating content I got up to making
three videos a day on my main channel I
get on a call with Matt Gillen who's one
of four people in the world who they
gave me advice on YouTube I would really
strongly deeply think about it I respect
him and three of the people that much
and he told me Evan you need to split up
your channel Evan doing three videos a
day on the same channel hurts you and
you just split it up into multiple
channels that was an impossible choice I
mean for me was it was scary it was
difficult I don't know the outcome so I
asked some other friends of mine
somebody else in the top forum and he
says that is the biggest mistake you
could make don't do it it's a huge
mistake for your channel it'll hold you
back so now what do I do there's four
people in the world whose opinions I
respect and trust on this one topic and
two of them are giving me exact opposite
advice what do I do
for me the decision was easy the action
was difficult it was tough but we do
tough things right we're entrepreneurs
here's my decision-making process
I would rather no one fail than not know
going my current course of making a few
videos a day on one channel I know what
that looks like I'm liking my success
I'm liking my growth but splitting up my
channels and going down to one video a
day on my main channel I didn't know if
they would work and if I don't try I'll
never know so even though one person I
really respect tells me it's the biggest
mistake of my life it may be it may be
the worst decision that I ever make in
my youtube career but I won't know
unless I try and I would rather live my
life without regrets knowing that I got
the information instead of being afraid
to act and so I split it up and listen
right now it's actually not working
right now the views on my main channel
are down the subscribers on my main
channel are down the amount of money I
make for my main channel is down and my
other channels like this one haven't
grown enough to combat it
to replace it what I'm still soldiering
on I'm still continuing down this path
now if it's a year and it's still the
same thing okay maybe I have to go back
to my old strategy but at least I would
know and so you can look at that and say
well you lost all that opportunity yeah
I made a mistake but I'd rather know and
fail than not know because if you only
take safe bets if you only take the bets
that you know you're gonna win it with a
hundred percent certainty then you play
small for life then you're only gonna
take on the projects that there's zero
risk of failure which means you stay in
this tiny circle I don't want to live in
a tiny circle I want to change the world
I want to have a huge impact that comes
with a great deal of failure just like
all your heroes rule number 42 be
impatient with yourself you need to be
more impatient with yourself but patient
with the results flip it
most people are impatient with the
results you want the money right now you
want the customers right now you want
the views right now you want the
subscribers right now but you're patient
with yourself you let yourself off the
hook all the time you procrastinate and
don't put in 100% effort that needs to
change flip it be more patient with the
results and impatient with yourself
because if you're impatient with
yourself if you domained 100% effort of
yourself every single day I guarantee
you the results will come rule number 43
act now the decisions that you make when
you're feeling bold or actually the
right ones for you and your head starts
talking you down from doing them when
you're feeling bold unstoppable
confident powerful and you make a
decision you make a choice you say I'm
gonna go off and do this thing that is
actually the best thing that you need to
go off and do you have to listen to it
you have to take that jump otherwise you
will still be in the same spot you are
currently in right now five years from
today so I just came back from doing a
tour 90 day tour 23 different cities it
all started because I was walking down
the street on a warm summer day last
year and
I'm gonna take Nina my wife to every
city in North America with a million
plus people quizzical all right my next
evolution the next leap the next jump
every city North America with my wife
let's go
and then your head gets in the way then
your head starts thinking well how many
cities are there how do we plan for this
Nina has a full-time job how are we
gonna make it all work what's the time
I'm gonna be your default first step
needs to be action instead of thinking
what most of us will do as soon as you
come with an idea is you go home and you
think and you plan and you ponder and
you strategize and you think and you use
all of your creative bold confident
energy into planning the problem is you
wake up the next day a different person
you wake up the next day thinking I
can't do that I can't go to every city
in North America with million-plus
people I can't do this I can't do that
you come up with all the reasons that
are logical that are practical as to why
you can no longer do that thing you were
feeling bold and confident yesterday but
today you can't do it that's why your
default first step needs to be action
use that bold creative powerful energy
into action into committing yourself to
doing something and taking what I call
the first 2% the 2% difference that
means don't go home and plan your way to
hitting 100% of your goal immediately
take the first 2% action to move a tiny
bit closer to your goal and so I said
I'm gonna take my wife Nina every city
in North America million-plus people
great what's my first step not
researching how many city's not trying
to figure out how Nina's gonna quit her
job not any of that stuff not planning
not strategizing it's this weekend we're
gonna go to Boston because I knew Boston
had a million-plus people and I knew
Nina hadn't been there yet so we're
gonna go to Boston it was actually the
wrong plant it wasn't the closest city I
thought it was the closest city but
there's multiple cities that are closer
with the imperfect plan that you act on
is better than the perfect plan that you
sit on and never do anything about and
so we went to Boston that weekend it was
a Wednesday afternoon I decided by
Friday night we were leaving and driving
to Boston action this is the thing that
most people are missing you don't have
action the 2% difference stop planning
to 100% and figure out what the smallest
possible simplest version of doing that
thing is right now immediately today
rule number 44 don't take no for an
answer swap your nose for not yet no
it's so final no means it's over there's
no path right it's a no it's final it's
over finish line we're done right
not yet means there's still the Scylla
path and I think for any entrepreneur
part of what we're doing is so visionary
it's so different it's so new there's
gonna be a lot of people who don't agree
with what you're doing because you're
challenging the status quo because
you're trying to do something that
hasn't been done before and there's a
lot of people who like the way that it's
happening right now and so most people
make decisions from their brain just a
logical practical side of their brain
we're entrepreneurs what we do best is
we make decisions from our heart and so
the brain can only imagine a world that
currently exists right it's logical
practical is what currently exists where
your heart can create something brand
new that hasn't existed yet before yet
and so you got to turn the nose when
somebody says no that's not gonna happen
you're never gonna make it you're not
good enough you don't have the resources
you don't have the knowledge you don't
have the connections you don't come from
the right family you're not born in the
right country right whatever that I know
is just turn it into not yet just wait
just watch me I'm coming
rule number 45 rise above pain if you
want to be a successful entrepreneur
you're going to have to deal with a lot
of pain
there will be a moment when you feel
like things just can't get any worse
you're at the bottom and then the POW
life hits you in the face and that
moment will define you if you're gonna
quit and give up go back to having a job
or you're gonna learn to rise above and
start having success as an entrepreneur
the strategy that I like to use is it's
the best you take whatever negative
situation you're in whatever that thing
that feels overwhelming all-consuming
impossible to deal with and you tell
yourself this is the best this thing is
happening to me right now is the best
this is my chance to show myself and the
world what I made up it's the best
and in actuality it is the best because
we very rarely get chances to show
ourselves what we're made of we very
rarely actually put ourselves into these
situations where we get hit in the face
rule number 46 make products that you
love making a product that people love
starts with you making something that
you love really think about it
would you buy from you would you
subscribe to you would you comment and
tell your friends about you in our rush
to get rich to make money we push
products out that we don't love and if
you don't love them people around you
won't love them either so look at my
youtube channel as an example I love my
youtube channel I make my youtube
channel for myself I learn it's selfish
it's for me the top 10 rules videos the
ants press'll videos the content that I
bring together I need it it's my
education I love my channel I would
share my channel with other people if I
saw my channel and I wasn't created be
the first thing that I subscribe to it
would be much watch YouTube for me I
need it and if you guys didn't like it I
would still create it for myself it
wouldn't have as much editing and fancy
effects and all that stuff but I would
still do it because I need it for me I
make it for myself
selfishly and then I share it with you
guys and thankfully you guys like enough
that I can turn a business from it and
continue to hire teamm and create more
content and pump more stuff out but as
much as I think that my channel still
needs to get better and grow and improve
and I still suck and I need to
continuously get better at the work that
I do I think my channel deserves a Nobel
Peace Prize like I think my channel is
amazing and you have to love what you do
you have to feel like the thing that
you're doing yes can always get better
but this is really solving a problem
your product your service what you
create your expertise solves a problem
you know that it's genuinely helping
people if you don't have that belief
you're never gonna win rule number 47
use technology to your advantage there
are three ways to use technology and
most people pick the one method that
costs them money you can be entertained
you can be educated and you
create entertained educated create the
first one costs you money entertainment
the second one is an investment
education and the third one makes you
money create the answer isn't to dump
your phone and delete all social media
it's to use these insanely powerful
tools to help you make money and achieve
your goals so what I want you to do is
now evaluate how are you using
technology and where does it fall into
those three categories entertain educate
and create I'll use me as an example
I'll go first you go next so for me let
me look at YouTube as an example great
number one entertain very little the
only entertainment content that I
consume on YouTube is gonna be one music
which is really more just getting my
state into an energetic positive one and
two on the weekends League of Legends
watching my team
TSM hopefully carry the day other than
that I don't spend any time on
entertainment content people send me
links to videos if Alex comes in and
wants to show me some silly videos like
dude I'm working I don't want to be
entertained right now I got stuff to do
I want to go crush it on my goals on my
dreams I got a lot that I need to get
done today don't send me this stuff to
educate I use YouTube a lot YouTube is
my number one source for education more
than books more than podcasts more than
anything else conferences anything
YouTube is where I learn video content
is where I learn most of my time spent
on YouTube is researching and reviewing
video clips that I am personally getting
inspired by that then I want to share
with you if I am making a video that I'm
sharing with you on any of my channels
is because I have learned something from
them so I'm spending most of my time on
YouTube being educated and then number
three is creating and creating a lot
we're doing three videos a day across my
seven channels so I'm creating so I'm
using YouTube not just as a way that
cost me money right that I have to go
spend money to buy something but I'm
using it to invest into myself as well
as to create content and then generates
a return as I can build a business
around it rule number 48 raise your
standards
expecting excellent starts with you
expecting excellence from yourself
people want to work for people who they
aspire to be like if someone excellent
is working for you but they have higher
standards than you do they will
eventually leave you your company's
limit is your standards so I look at
Alex as an example who helps me run
Toronto dance salsa I invest into the
company a number of years ago I became
the 100% owner in it and then I'm
training Alex to run it one of the
things that Alex had an issue was was
showing up on time we had low standards
for himself of being on time if you said
be here at 10 o'clock
he would be here at 10:15 or 10:20 and
that just became what he was known for
everybody knew alex is the guy who
didn't follow through who came late the
things and that was Alex great some
people are willing to put up with it
some people will tolerate it because
they like his energy his enthusiasm his
fun his bravado they like it and they
have low standards for themselves
by high achievers people who have high
standards that would drive them nuts and
people would leave the business people
would not want to work with them people
would want to go somewhere else because
their standards are higher than the
person that they're supposed to be
working for nobody wants to be in a
situation you do not want to work for
somebody who has lower standards than
you do and so the challenge became Alex
we need to raise your standards you need
to start showing up not just on time but
early for him now it's ten minutes early
so if we said is gonna be here at 10:00
that means you're there at 9:50 you're
there at 10:00 to 10:00 you have to be
so you're late
if you show up at 10 o'clock for Alex
him as his own standards that somebody
else if you're showing up at 10 o'clock
and you say you're gonna be there at 10
o'clock he's late to himself that's a
starting point and as his standards have
risen so have the people underneath his
team who are willing to follow him as
your standards rise as you care more
about yourself in what you're doing and
what you will no longer accept and
tolerate then the people who are working
for you their standards rise as well
and you're able to now attract a much
wider pool because they want to level up
people want to be around you yes for
your mission but they want to level up
with your responsibility to help people
level up and so if you're only at this
point as soon as somebody gets here
they're leaving but as you can go here
then you can attract a lot of people
underneath who want to level up and
they're gonna learn from you not just
the knowledge but the abilities the
mindset the hustle the energy the drive
that you pour into your business will be
an inspiration to other people when you
raise your own standards rule number 49
stop comparing to others you need to
stop judging your version of balance
against someone else's I think this is
something that plagues at least the
North American culture we're constantly
comparing what makes us happy against
somebody else's likes you have a version
of balance you have a version of
happiness you have a version of passion
it's different for everybody I can't
judge you for what you're doing
the only test is are you proud of
yourself do your actions map to your
ambitions is what's in your calendar a
reflection of what will make you happy
and I think as soon as you can get into
your own head as soon as you can
understand what happiness and balance
and success looks like for you and stop
comparing it against somebody else's
version in your life for an Instagram
that's when you can actually go off and
find the success you're after and rule
number 50 the very last one before a
very special bonus clip is tie yourself
worth to the effort you need to tie
yourself worth to the effort not the
results if you tie your self-worth to
the results to achieving your goals then
you'll only take on things that you
think you have a high chance of winning
at you'll constantly quit on your big
goals and only go after the small ones
tie yourself for two trying to the
effort to doing it when it's hard make
yourself proud with the effort that you
put in not just when you win but if you
keep getting up every day and putting in
effort that you are proud of you will
Wayne on a level that you never thought
was possible
got a special bonus cook from Evan that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's but before that here's the mmm
but before that but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions it's time to go from just
watch it it's time to go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go
question number one who are three people
in your life that you need to let go of
question number two where are you
playing small in your life right now
number three what are you gonna do this
week to build your self-esteem just
because you're following your passion
doesn't mean you're gonna make money
doing it but I don't think you have to
go work a job that you hate for a decade
until you earn the right to go off and
do the thing that you love I think in a
2019 2020 environment we've proven that
it doesn't have to take an insane amount
of time for you to achieve financial
success the trick is to figure out how
can you combine that thing that you love
doing with something that serves other
people so that you can make money doing
it and it's not just a hobby for you
that fills your soul but I believe that
the fastest way to make a lot of money
is to be an entrepreneur not to be an
employee somewhere else and if you want
to be an entrepreneur the lesson that
comes up over and over and over and over
again from all the people that I profile
is you have to do the thing that you
love you have to follow your passion
otherwise think about it you're going up
against people who love the thing that
they're doing you are competing with
somebody who absolutely loves this thing
and for you it's just a strategy you're
gonna lose the people who love what
they're doing will beat you every single
day of the week and so instead of
fighting an unfair fight you want to
tilt the odds in your favor and do the
thing that you love if you want to see
Evans video on seven ways to start a
business with no cash click right here
concedes you believe and I'll see you
there I'm gonna show you how to do it in
seven different ways how you can make
money and start the business without any
startup capital here we go